the honeydew with y'all
thank you for your support here's ryan
sickler
welcome back to the honeydew with y'all
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pants studios thank you so much
for your support we've got a lot of new
subscribers here in the uh community
hearing it on ymh bertcast i [ __ ]
love you all come in you get the entire
back catalog audio and or video
you get yma or excuse me
i said ymh you get the uh episode a day
early ad free at no additional cost and
if you sign up for a year you're getting
uh over a month of free episodes all
right if you or someone you know has
that story that has to be heard please
submit it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com we'll veto them we do have a
lot of submissions i've even emailed
some of you back and you haven't
responded because you probably thought
oh they aren't interested we are it
could take a month or so to get to we
got a lot of [ __ ] going on over here so
be patient but i'm telling you if your
story just jumps out we're having you um
and
the episodes are just
we this one right here we're about to do
today is the first time uh subject we've
ever had on this show hell there there
might not be a lot of these on tv all
right
uh making making some honeydew with you
all history here ladies and gentlemen
please welcome joe cheller welcome to
the honeydew with the all joe
how's it going it's going good my man
how are you
i'm doing good living the dream all
right well i uh i love that you're here
with us you have
a [ __ ] crazy story we're gonna hear
but before we do
uh where are you in the world right now
joe
i'm up in northern illinois okay
northern illinois all right and uh how
old are you i'm uh 27. another young
[ __ ] i love it all right uh and
what do you do for a living
i'm a land surveyor a land sir what is
actually a land sir are you the guys
that stand out in the [ __ ] street
with the tripod and just look at [ __ ]
yeah um but my company we do a lot more
with drones and uh gps and robots so i'm
a little bit more high tech than the uh
the guys you see underneath the
teamsters leaning on the [ __ ] shovels
all right
god bless y'all on your on your eight
hour lunch break
um okay
this is um as i said this is an episode
something we've never dealt with before
so
let me just say this uh and i won't
get rid of the ending yet but
you were working a job
your email says and you found a human
skull is that right
yep sure did it all right stop right
there don't even there was because i
know you're used to this and you're
gonna zoom right by it
walk me through the day where are you
what time of year is this where are you
in the world what are you doing exactly
and how do you [ __ ] stumble upon this
so i'm uh
it's about
probably two fridays right before
christmas
because i remember it was a friday
because fridays we work half days i
think it was just i think it was
december 19th right around there about
the time i had my covenant anniversary
right around
so uh
there i'm kind of close to aurora
illinois if you know where that is i do
and um they're building a new public
works building something like that and
i'm in the woods trying to show where
they're gonna have to start start
cutting down trees okay now at this part
of the this point of the woods where you
are this is still obviously i haven't
like broke ground yet or anything
because you're out there to do that yeah
pre-pre that but
how far away are you from isolation or
but or are you very close to a name i
can there's a train tracks um there's a
main road to get into the surrounding
towns
i mean you're not in like the hills of
west virginia type [ __ ] at all no i'm
probably
from like
a mcdonald's i'm probably two miles away
holy [ __ ] okay so it's rural so for sure
no i mean it's not rural i'm sorry yeah
i'm the closest to the interstate is
five miles north of where i'm at oh so
like i'm
i'm right by aurora i'm you know i'm not
far from anything
so i'm walking through the woods
marking where they're gonna cut down
these uh the trees so they can clear it
and get ready for breaking ground and uh
it just rained that day so i'm not very
uh
i'm pretty clumsy
so i was walking and i noticed this
this tan rock sitting out and i go well
i'm not gonna step on that because i'm
gonna break my ankle and there's nobody
gonna i had to climb over a creek to get
here it's like a dinosaur egg it looks
like a dinosaur egg bro about to be a
billionaire nobody's gonna pull my 250
pound body out of here
so i said all right i'm going to step
next to it so i stepped on a stick
next to it and it popped the rock i'm
like well that's not normal and i turn
and two eyes or two eye socket look
right up at me
oh get the [ __ ] outta did you [ __ ]
yourself or what bro
so first thing i did is i i had my
equipment and i mean this equipment's 80
000 dropped it
and i was like so i actually worked for
my dad my dad is the head surveyor at
the company
and he's on vacation he's actually in
maine at the time
so i call him and i said hey
i think i just found a human scholar go
shut up no you didn't
all right hold on
are you out there by yourself or do you
have a team there's no there's not even
an assistant with you it's just shoot by
yourself oh [ __ ] okay so first call is
to dad
who's who owns the company who's been
doing this for [ __ ] probably decades
right
um this year will be his 30th year
he could find what you [ __ ] found
so he goes no way he goes that's really
cool and i go i i mean i knew it he goes
take a picture first
i'm like i'm not taking a picture of
this and what year is this
oh this was um
2020.
you had to think about it was last year
well i wanted to make sure i had my math
no i found it
eight months ago actually it looks like
it might be
it might be eight months to the day that
we're taping this wow all right
so i do that i call him and he goes well
go back to the truck you know i'm about
half a mile from my truck and said all
right like he's like i'm gonna call
the sheriff's department we'll get them
out there for you so i get to my
i go over the wood i go through the
woods over the you know over this creek
and uh
i get to my truck and i just throw up
i'm talking all over my truck
now did it did this did the skull stick
was there any flesh on it hair did it
stink was it
it didn't smell it didn't have anything
it was um and you knew right away that
this was definitely not some halloween
[ __ ] some kid buried like you know
i've seen well i've i've grew up hunting
so i've seen deer bone i've seen
real bonuses yellow this is fantastic
yeah yeah
so i i i did that and i called him and
then i grew up all over here
and then after that i ended up calling
my wife and i was like
hey i found a human skull and she goes
well that's gross and i go no a real one
she goes oh real what
[Laughter]
so i uh and then by that time the police
are calling they're like hey where are
you where are you
you know i tell them that one cop shows
up i'm like all right cool like let's go
on this hike man
so we go through there
and then by the time we get there and
real quick is he does he have his hand
on his [ __ ]
his piece the whole time wondering if
you might be the [ __ ] that did
this cause i i would i'd make you walk
in front of me and i'd be right on that
[ __ ] like this like y'all i think when
he saw the puke on the truck he probably
figured it wasn't
so he ended up we got there and by the
time we got there there's 20 cop cars
the public works director's there
the whole nine is there and the uh
they tape it off and the sheriff come or
the uh yeah sheriff comes up and he goes
with his dunkin and his hand i remember
this
wait a donut or the coffee bro
okay
he left the donut in the trunk
he gets five feet away from it and goes
yeah that's a human skull we got a
murder and i'm like what
it was just crazy to be able
and then uh
so we get back i get back to my truck my
other boss ends up showing up
and we have to go over there and do
everything collect our inch we end up
couldn't collect any of our equipment
for three weeks because they had to keep
it in place in case there was oh [ __ ]
any sort of stuff on it um they ended up
finding
um shoes and everything like that that
was around it so they were like oh this
could be it they kept finding all this
other stuff so it took them what took
them about three months to finally comb
the area clear because this is where
that city ended up dropping their um
like roadkill it was in this woods
because it was so close to the
municipality building so they had to
have a team of bone experts come out and
actually check each bone individually
that are found by the raccoon
that's what it was
i guess there's a deer bone and a human
bone that you can't tell the difference
oh is that right
i'm pretty sure the skulls look
different
i'm pretty sure there weren't a bunch of
[ __ ] chimpanzees and [ __ ] running
back in that area
anything that resembled us at all
oh [ __ ] and then if we fast forward to
the next time i'm at the job site they
make me go out there alone again
as i'm leaving they say hey don't find
another human i go all right well i hope
not
they had these little pink flags in the
ground where they found bones
when i say scattered this was in a mine
this was in a two acre area
i'm saying from one corner to the other
to the other all over that animals had
drug the bones god there was one they
had to upheave a fox then
and they said they pulled out like six
or seven different bones
the fox are just down there and gnawing
on a human bone and [ __ ]
man so savage [ __ ] going on out in the
[ __ ] woods without us knowing about
it yeah it was just it was crazy and
then you know i ended up talking to uh
it was just crazy that you know the guy
that was out there before me doing some
other work for our company he could have
been right there and he would have never
known because of if it was green at the
time i only saw it because it was winter
so we had no leaves
and i was like i'm not going to trip and
hurt myself well
talk about finding something that every
surveyor dreams to find i know it's
something gross but it's it's a cool
i've had a few guys that i've worked
with at different companies that um
will be looking for a property corner in
the wood or in the
in the corn fields because we dig them
deeper
and they'll that one guy found a full
person closed what the f
that's buried alive probably
i don't know
let me have it joe let me out they were
buried alive yeah and then they shot
them
[Laughter]
so uh
and then if we fast forward a couple
more so i'm sorry you know someone that
you know that person that found the
clothed body oh you do yeah we used to
work together at the last surveying
company i worked at that was actually
out in the boonies so are you two like
the only two g's that have found dead
bodies in the like you two have a
connection
uh it's actually really common for
surveyors to find dead bodies because
we're humans
we're talking i'm not talking about just
animal bodies no humans because we're
out in those spots where nobody thinks
that everyone's going to look
like no one thinks cheesecake's going to
break ground over here for another
restaurant yeah exactly but yeah well
they think that uh well they know that
the guy that ended up doing it
knew that they dropped
the
roadkill there so he figured oh nobody's
going to question if it smells
if there's bones over here
so but we go in those spots and we have
to no matter what i mean i was just
working at a slaughterhouse the other
day so i mean we're everywhere that you
don't want to be right okay unlike
american express
um or no visa it's visa it's visa visa
um okay so
america's press never leave home without
it uh visas everywhere you want to be
you're uh you're like the anti-visa all
right i am yes all right so now they
know they have a murder they are you
allowed to be there when they take any
of that uh land do they ask you they
interviewing you are they questioning
you
i did not want to be a part of it um
they took my information but i think
because
of how young i am
because they could tell right away that
it wasn't fresh
and with how young i am that they were
like well there's this person is no way
at all uh
suspect i see so i never got asked
anything i never got interviewed uh
never got the rant never got the uh
reward pretty rude there was a reward
yep how much that's five thousand
dollars get they who do who can't scrape
up five g's for finding somebody's skull
who who put that reward up the police or
the family i think it was the family so
i don't know where they want they
probably they probably got a drug addict
in the family that ran through that five
like it was nothing all right let's let
them have but they lost they have a loss
they have a loss yeah so uh
and then it was right i think it was
i wanna say like the 23rd of the same
month
my wife sends me this link and says hey
i think this is their press release from
the city of the body
so i know how many days later
uh it was like four or five so it was
that next week and finally through
dental records and just stuff in the
bone they finally got it figured out and
was it a male or female who was it was a
it was a female um she had been dead for
18 years
years
years yeah bro hold on you helped
you found a skull on your work site and
helped solve an 18 year old [ __ ] cold
case for real
it gets better man it gets better
i love these goddamn [ __ ]
go ahead tell me more please the
boyfriend was already in jail for her
disappearance
and they actually found the the bullet
in her head that attached to his gun yep
they found the [ __ ] bullet in the
skull you found and it matched the
boyfriend's gun
yep because he didn't he only used a 22
round caliber so it didn't go all the
way through
jesus christ
holy [ __ ] dude you helped solve an 18
well first of all
congratulations and good for you i'm
sure that
i want to ask you about the family but
but
how [ __ ] terrible is the aurora
police department that this shit's right
there for eight i thought you're gonna
say 18 months i really didn't say 18
years no that's why so i was nine when
this murder happened
holy [ __ ] 18 years i feel like no one
was even really putting half-assed
effort into this [ __ ] case well so
that was i don't know if you knew about
drew peterson if you ever heard anything
about that
why do i know that is that lacy peterson
is that was a cop out this way that
killed like four of his five wives
oh no is that the is that lacey peterson
husband or is that a different peterson
i don't know it might be somebody
different okay he killed how many of his
wives four out of the five i think or
something like that
he must love that one
but he was a lot he was a law
enforcement officer out this way so i
think a lot of people were focusing on
that so a lot of this stuff got kind of
pushed to the side is what their thought
process was
or if this person had put the body
underneath a dead deer or something
afterwards you would i mean i'm not
going to go out there and move over the
dead gears to check for under under
stuff
no [ __ ] that right that's not your job
yeah
do you find out how old was this girl
when she was murdered do you know um she
was she was uh 25. oh when she was
murdered and have you do you know it
like the reaction from the family once
they were notified have you had any
contact with them i would want to
[ __ ] thank you i would
i kind of um i gave the police my
information i haven't really been super
vocal about it um
just because i don't
i don't know i mean i i'd meet him if
they were open to it i'd love to talk to
him she actually had two kids
at the time one of them was my one of
them is my age now and one of them's a
few years younger than me so she had
three and this one's the her daughter
that's killed oh so one of the kids was
the the woman that was killed was one of
them had two kids that were my age oh
i'm sorry i thought you were talking
about the mom of the woman killed okay
so
how was she
and had two kids already huh
man they all started young
so it was uh it would have been
interesting to talk to them and i i just
like to tell myself i gave them kind of
like a uh
a christmas present you know i finally
gave him that closure after 18 years of
not knowing
because i guess in the police report it
said that the day of her disappearance
she was living with her sister
and uh she had left in a hurry dropped
her kids off
at their parents and left all the
candles going in the house and the oven
on
so they think that
it was kind of a rude to get her out of
the house as quickly as possible
and then she met the person somewhere
because there was no forced entry or
anything like that so this case had been
open for 18 years so wait i'm a little
confused here what do you mean about the
candles and the what do you
so when
the day of her disappearance
she had dropped her her sons off at her
mom's house and when her sister got home
all the candles were still lit i see and
the oven was still on so her sister knew
something was wrong
because so they think that
well now they know that the boyfriend
had convinced her to leave in a hurry
about something
and then oh to like come meet me right
away i need your help or since she was
like it's an emergency and she just
exactly gotcha so she left everything
going so i mean that could have burnt
down the whole apartment complex and
stuff like that so that's how kind of
the police knew right away that this
wasn't just somebody ran away or did
something so
now do you know who this guy is or is
there any and is there an article on
this you could give me a link to that i
conclude in the post for people to see
yeah i can send you uh i'd have to find
it i can look it up if i just have to
i'd have to google it and then just send
you the uh the press release they're
really vague about it
but um like i don't get mentioned at all
they don't say hero joe sheller they
don't [ __ ] even throw that out bro if
i find one more body i'm quitting my job
and becoming a detective that's all and
then you'll never find another one
well they're not finding them out there
that's what i'm saying that's exactly
what i'm saying we need you [ __ ] land
surveyors out there find these dead
bodies for us man someone's got to get
closure
god damn
so
um this guy who did this he was already
in prison just because they were like
i'm assuming they had a
history
i think they had it was her boyfriend
and i or fiance or something along those
lines but i think they had already had
him in prison this is what i've heard
from the police
because i talked to some of them um
afterwards so they kind of already knew
what was going on so i knew of all this
before
the trial and everything like that and
that they had already had him in custody
for the past couple years for her
disappearance because they linked enough
and they had a jury to prove him guilty
of doing it so he has already been in
jail for it and then this is kind of now
they're trying him as a trialing him as
a murderer
and you didn't you didn't you didn't you
didn't go to any of the cases or any of
that stuff no um i don't think it would
have been necessary i mean just to say i
i mean just to find about it's a cool
story but i don't think it would have
swayed anybody in any sort of direction
so how has it made you feel after like
do you feel good about you know
helping um obviously the ladies gone but
18 years i mean good god that's a that's
enough time to to grow an adult
yeah i mean it it does feel
when i found out that she had the two
sons and they were my age it did really
feel
surreal i mean it felt good to give that
that those people finally have that
closure and they could bury their mom i
don't know how hard it would be to know
18 years and just not know well i'm 48
and you're 27 i think you said yeah so
what if in 21 years from now one of
these young men reaches out to you would
you be open to talking to them or you
know yeah
definitely i mean they could reach out
to me tomorrow and i'd be well hopefully
they subscribe hey if you all subscribe
hit joe up man hit him up in the
comments
it was it was like i said i mean
the the
the first thing that went through my
head when i found it was who's out here
with me
because you know obviously there's no
there's no hair there's no eyes in it
but you don't think that when you find
that skull you don't think oh this is
old it's fine no you think who's out
here right now with a gun right who just
put this here 10 seconds ago and then
they're gonna see me and i'm gonna be
next right yeah yeah
so it was that was the first thing i
went through my head and when he told me
go back to the truck i
never walked that fast through a forest
in my life
so it was i it was and then i had to
climb over a tree to get over the creek
it was how long was your walk back to
the truck before you threw up
um it was about a 15-minute walk that's
a long time that's almost a mile
alone there with your thoughts that's
what i'm saying so what is
what is going through your head when
you're walking back and is it daytime
still at this point what time of day or
early morning it's probably like 8 a.m
so at that time it's still a little dark
it's not crazy out here but it's still
dark you know it's quiet there's not a
lot of people because it's right around
christmas time so a lot of people aren't
going to work right now it's very quiet
so i'm walking there and i'm just
thinking i need to get back to my truck
where i know it's safe i'm going to lock
the doors and i'm just going to wait
to either die or the police show
up no
um i walked very fast i because i knew
if i ran i'd fall and hurt myself
because it was icy out and i'm like i'm
not can't beat a white chick in the
horror film joe
i was there i uh
i ended up i just i put on some music
and i
just wanted and just tried to keep my
mind away from anything else how long
before you threw up
right when i got to my right when you
hit it i i got to my truck i opened the
door and i turned and just covered our
logo on the back of the truck
just
it was great what uh what was it what do
you what was it that finally made you so
sick what turned your stomach enough i
think i think that when i left my fight
or flight motion had kicked in so i
that's all i thought about my body said
you don't need to you don't need to you
don't need to you don't need to pee you
don't need to do anything
behind you you need to get to your truck
it's safe and i got to my truck you know
i could see the sun because there was no
trees i could i could see a few cars
like oh cool if someone kills me here
somebody's going to see it it's fine and
then my body goes hey you know what else
would be fun
throw up right now
so i just it's
here
out of pure just adrenaline
fear
and i mean i after that i i've told
enough i i i bawled my eyes onto the
police got there i was terrified i mean
you did oh yeah oh for and then i cried
on the way home
um yeah i mean i'm just picturing right
now keith morrison with the hole it was
a december morning in aurora
that's a normal day in a normal
neighborhood or was it he'll do that
[ __ ] that's yeah that's what it felt
like that's i mean
i see it there's still a little dark
it's out there in those
weird wooded area a [ __ ] skull pops
up man oh man i don't give a [ __ ] i'd
have been hustling
i don't know if it popped up in the air
i might have kicked it i still got my
juco skills you know
i'm joking i'm juggling it out there
do a nice little scissor kick see how
large you go
still got its molars
so what
go ahead the worst part is too that
there's an abandoned railroad track
there with a box car that's been known
to have a lot of meth heads chilling out
in there
so i thought that's another reason i
wanted to get out there because i was
like what if this was like a drug deal
gone bad or anything like that so i was
like you know what i need to get out of
here and so you just never know in the
woods i mean it's
it's i mean our job is safe most the
time if we don't have to worry about
people hitting us on the highway but i
mean i'm more scared of being in the
woods alone right now anyway
yeah do you uh do you carry a weapon on
you
um sometimes not what's your weapon of
choice
when i worked for my last company i'd
carry my nine mil with me [ __ ] yeah okay
good but now um a lot you gotta worry
about animals too in the woods not just
[ __ ] people not murder i mean you're
more likely obviously to
to get attacked by an animal than to
[ __ ] find a dead body maybe not in
that neighborhood but everywhere else
but now with the company i work for
because we work for a lot when i found
the body a lot we do a lot of state work
so i can't do that type of stuff
so i just have a pocket knife with me
anymore
you don't got a little ankle holster or
something
i won't tell i can't even touch my toes
why would that do good for me down there
oh no i've fallen
oh [ __ ] man this is wild so
uh they find they they start doing it
you say three months they excavate the
land they do they end up putting her
whole body back together or they
i mean i think for the most part um from
what i've heard i think
some of it might have been pulled to
different spots just
it's 18 years man i mean it's been odd
and with the creek there bones after a
while can start to float
so they said if something could have
fallen in there like a pinky toe
that's gone
yeah i'm sorry what are you gonna do
about the pain
that's the least of my worries i mean
real i got you guys the skull yeah i
mean i got you the part where you wear
the hat you know what i mean you all can
get the socks part yeah it wasn't an
open casket by any means
so
um
do you has it [ __ ] with you since i
mean this is recent so have you had
nightmares have you
what what's sort of like i mean that's a
big deal you found that you you didn't
just find a dead body of someone who was
homeless and wandered off passed away or
even suicide you found the body of
of a life that was taken by another
human being so how has it affected you
so those first few nights i i slept
really bad sweats
woke up screaming a few times crying you
know just
just not knowing what to feel because
well
i looked up as the skull was moving so
imagine two eyes looking up at you
[Laughter]
not a very good picture
she was scared the [ __ ] out of me
scared the [ __ ] out of me especially
it's not noon it's not 90 degrees and a
t-shirt and shorts it's [ __ ] cold ass
december quiet ass still i oh man i
that's the thing i love the woods i
really do love the woods especially at
that time
but it's always creepy yeah i would i
would no longer be a fan i bet y'all can
[ __ ] your camp and i spit all in my
drink
so uh you know and then that bullet hole
right here really got to me
that one
yeah
it was right between your eyes oh man
but now um
i'm
i'm not a really i mean i'm still
affected by it it's still every now and
then talking about it and bringing it up
it's just like i mean i waited a few
months to contact just because it was
one of those things where it's like am i
ready to
um
but i finally you know i was like yeah i
think i am and
you know just talking it over with
people and saying enough times you
realize that you know there's nothing
that i could have done
but i'm just glad that at the end of the
day these kids finally get to closure
joe let me tell you i want to give you
props man that's not nothing you could
have done you did in your situation
coming across this person you did
everything you could and what you did
was finally give those people peace of
mind look as a you said you have
children
no okay well i do and i couldn't imagine
18 years of being on this planet going
by without them and then all of a sudden
one day right before christmas
this [ __ ] news comes i mean man oh
man that is a hell of a [ __ ]
christmas present
so that was and uh yeah it was
i mean it was crazy and
i like i said i'm just glad i could help
but i mean now walking through the woods
is
not as fun
um do you find yourself looking for [ __ ]
all the time i've found um
if i find a bone i don't know what it is
i like to look around for a few more to
make sure it's not anything because we
go into some pretty seedy areas
sometimes like where what are you what
are you doing like the south south side
of chicago and harlem uh yeah our hearty
um illinois
like we if we have to clear out certain
areas like to take like a to show it on
like a like if we have to open up a
manhole and if there's leaves on it we
don't use our boots we'll use a shovel
because i've kicked stuff with my boot
and had hypodermic needles
that's baltimore city like when you walk
down the sidewalk of baltimore city and
at the end of the day you pick your
shoes up you'll have little vials
cracked in them and [ __ ] like that
they're every you're not avoiding it
yeah
so we we i mean i've been in places
where um
our our instruments are very expensive
so we'll have one guy sit there either
in the truck or we'll have um somebody
sit standing there with just a machete
hooked onto the side of their belt yeah
because a lot of surveyors will wear one
anyway so if they just see us wearing
one
a lot of them won't mess with you um
but i mean we've i've had people tell me
stories that in some of the same areas
we've worked at where people will just
come in with a van and take all your
equipment off the side of the road and
just leave
yeah really just pull up grab it and go
one of our equipment's around sixty
thousand dollars holy [ __ ] what's that
little yellow thing i see y'all [ __ ]
blocking my traffic for and acting like
you're staring through a telescope how
much is that thing worth um so it
depends the one that i use is sixty
thousand the one that the guy i work
with uses seventy five damn
so what are you seeing through that
thing uh that's actually turning angles
based on where it knows itself at
so it's turning angles and it's actually
taking the elevation of the ground so it
can
it's it's just taken a lot of
measurements it's nothing crazy i mean
it's math
well yeah i'm not good at that
neither am i that's why my instrument
does it for me
so
um
do you find yourself disinterested now
in shows like dateline and and [ __ ] like
that or more interested
um
i i like to watch him alone because when
i watch him with friends
i get a lot of jokes all the time
so um i mean not that i care about the
jokes but sometimes if i'm really
interested in something i don't want to
be joking about it um
i get asked a lot when my book deals
coming out
um i mean has anyone contacted you about
this cold case closing or any date line
or any of that [ __ ] like
no probably after this i'll probably get
some messages but yeah i know i mean you
did you solved an 18 year old cold case
it's a really interesting story first
here on the honeydew breaking ground no
pun intended and
i'm making a little history over here
bro
um
man i i really hope they do someone
reaches out to you it's a story that
needs to to go out to the masses i don't
i mean we got it locked behind a pay
wall yeah it was a
it was interesting to be able to finally
do that or not finally be able to but
being one of those people that
you know because as a survey where it's
kind of a small community so we all kind
of talk and we we talk on reddit you
know a lot of us tell stories and to
finally be one of those people that find
it and be so young
i mean most of these guys have been
doing this for 40 50 years have never
even found one yeah how how long were
you in it again eight um so i started it
yeah i started it when i was 16. i
started doing this
so i've been doing it now for
what is that 12 10 11 years yeah so
you said how old are you 27 or 8 27 okay
um
did you end up finding out like did you
research the girl yourself and go back
and see who she was what she looked like
and lo a little bit about her story this
person you found in the ground the
article that the um newspaper actually
dropped or released had a lot of that
information
and when that had released and i found
her name i didn't i wasn't in the right
spot to be trying to find that stuff i
was still kind of shaken up for it i
took the next couple days off work or
that next week off work just to kind of
it's i you know it's like you said it's
a it's a human life being taken from
another person
right or by another person and that's
just kind of eye-opening to see that
people would do that and then that i
find the byproduct of it you don't you
never hear that when the body was found
you never hear about the person that
found it because you know they're a hero
but yeah we're here we're a hero to you
but
i have to live with
seeing that scot that skull look up at
me
and tried to you know it's just walking
through the woods is never the same for
me anymore it never will be does
halloween [ __ ] scare you when you see
skulls and she jump a little bit like no
i mean if probably have like a really
good haunted house but i mean now seeing
them i'm like yeah that's fake
i've seen
you guys don't have anything on me this
is weak would you buy this at the dollar
store
man you really did but yeah you know
i i i guess my so it's 2002 then if it's
an 18 year old cold case you found in
2020 so there's internet for sure
so it's probably out there
uh yeah and and it just hasn't gotten to
you yet where you want to know
who this person is exactly yeah i mean
i'll probably in the next couple days
you know after reopening it and seeing
how i i just want to see how i react
from this before i keep digging deeper
because you know it's one of those
things that
well you know this community now they
know it a murder in 2020
your name
uh you know un uh cold case aurora
illinois they'll find it for you they'll
find it for you
you're not good you're still dealing
with this joe well here's a detailed
article about everything you don't want
to know
here's everything have fun
reddit subreddits and all that [ __ ] are
going to be [ __ ] crazy
hey i mean if you do what you got to do
it's
not like i said it's it was just crazy
to be able to finally do that and
they're not finally you know making it
sound like it's
a goal of mine but it was interesting to
be able to help somebody and
be one of those few in illinois that
have found the dead body from the
serving doesn't it [ __ ] with you that
you have this is what's tripping me out
a little bit you we all have our own
life story we're all going this way in
our own lives
and
you
literally stepped
stepped
into
this whole other family and person's
lives with assorted boyfriend and uh
you know who knows what's going on with
her family the kids like
isn't that [ __ ] crazy how you were an
extra
you were a nobody in these people's
lives and now you've become a main
[ __ ] character
without ever even knowing them or
meeting them or anything like that trips
me out how how much of a storyline
you are now in their world that's crazy
to me
yeah you know actually i never thought
of it that way so now that's even more
um that's gonna mess with my mind a
little harder to talk to your therapist
about that definitely you're gonna be
brought up uh tomorrow but uh
you are
you were somebody to them would have
said you know hey how about joe sheller
who the [ __ ] joe scheller and then
right before christmas joe scheller
is you're you're one of their biggest
[ __ ] you're a main character you're a
main character in that storyline yeah
they might they might but
you mean the guy that found the skull
yeah
you know the one that the police they
took all the credit for
yeah right yeah which cop got the 5 000.
i think i think the uh
i think actually the sheriff took the
credit
that's [ __ ] low
yeah we uh we found a body no you didn't
joe's over here throwing up on his
[ __ ] truck crying just [ __ ]
himself
[Music]
i'm good
but i'm not i've never been that type of
person though where it's like
oh it's all about me like i shoulda you
know first of all good for you second of
all that's not what this is about like
go ahead and [ __ ] have your little
five-minute sheriff
you
you the sheriff can say whatever the
[ __ ] he wants he's a footnote in your
[ __ ] story remember
remember you know at the end of the day
my family my friends people that know
who i am know what really happened
and now all of y'all know who found who
what happened and it was just crazy to
be able to
i this is like you said that my life
intertwined with these random people
that i'll never i never knew never even
would have known yeah would never
and then i just pretty much probably
made him the happiest i know the mother
was the happiest she's ever been i'm
sure and do you know do you know if she
was even alive like that's the other
thing like
man it was finally closure yeah it would
suck to be a parent who died during this
18-year [ __ ] where they're gone and then
they find her and you don't even [ __ ]
get that closure like that would suck
that would suck up yeah that
that would be the worst part and i think
both of her parents are still alive
because i think it was something in the
article might have said something about
it at least the mother i know is i don't
know if the dad was in the picture well
hopefully those kids have their
grandparents or someone because uh one
well they're old as you now one of them
you said so he's a man but yeah one of
them's one of them's 27 and then i think
one was like 24 25 or something like
that so
they were young
i mean could you i mean they were eight
or nine when it happened
no and then for them for them so you got
a mother missing her child you've got
two boys missing their mom possibly a
husband missing his wife we don't know
well no she had a boyfriend but that
well the boyfriend did it so he ain't
missing nobody he ain't missing nobody
he's missing nothing but freedom well
then the sister you know she doesn't
have her do you know um if he's still in
he'll be in prison forever though now
right um
i don't i haven't heard anything new
about it like if they give him that
[ __ ] of 20
year life sentence but you've already
served 16 so you're out
okay i don't think it's allowed to
because of the fact that this is a
totally different case now because of
the fact that this was a disappearance
what he got tried for
and then now this is her murder so i
think i don't think that's a i don't
think they're allowed to do that has he
been tried is there uh has the case gone
to trial yet they said that the case was
going to trial quickly
but i like i said i didn't really do any
research on it just because of the fact
i was
like i'm not gonna lie i was kind of
scared i don't i didn't know how i would
react or what i would do it's scared of
what
just
myself not in anything like i was just
afraid of how i'd react or you know if
if
you i became close to these people and
i've never met them they don't know who
i am
and i became close to them because you
know they lost somebody and i helped
find them and then get that closure
where if i if i were to find out he was
found not guilt
mess with me a lot harder than if it was
just some random person that i'd you
know if it was just some random
news article it would be like oh like oh
that sucks but
where this is like well why wasn't he
guilty like i literally saw the evidence
in my it was i almost stepped on it yeah
this you know why is that not a thing
but i mean like i said it was one of
those things that i kind of pushed it to
the back of my head which i know isn't a
good thing to do but i was just like i
don't want to think about this right now
i've got other stuff going on
let's refocus this in five years when
i think about it yeah but
i guess i can't push it back any farther
it finally got to you where you needed
to get are you seeing a therapist or
anyone you talk to anyone about it
because of this or was it prior to it
i've been seeing one i've been seeing
one now for a few years well because of
you so a few years wow thank you are you
for real yeah yeah actually
good for you i'm pretty sure
don't quote me i usually
listen to you on monday and then watch
you on friday
okay so i probably was watching you that
morning
that i found the box oh
usually i watch you on either tuesdays
or fridays or tuesdays all right okay on
tuesday and you [ __ ] possibly watched
the honeydew and then went out who was
the episode i loved it
it was december 19th around that time
that's what i got
jeremiah watkins was right around then
he was the biggest crier we've ever had
he was in here felipe was in here during
uh december and i think or or he was
november adam ferrar we only did like
one or two
in december because we were shutting the
[ __ ] studio down because it was
filthy out here we were like let's get
away
um but it's probably jeremiah or adam
ferrara someone like that in december
so yeah i mean like i said it was
probably got the dew on and then went
out and found a poor [ __ ] honeydew
buried in the goddamn ground you were
involved
i'm honored to know i'm somehow involved
in helping find this poor lady that does
feel good dude i don't care it feels
good that was the soundtrack
the hunt the [ __ ] dateline episode
better have my honeydew theme music
riding when you find just me kicking the
bone kicking the skull over and i just
hear that laugh coming through my
headphones
oh man
now that that's your promo right there
god damn dude
so
um
talking to your therapist as your
therapist he or she ever heard anything
like this i can't imagine they have yeah
so what [ __ ] advice can some
therapist who's never had this
experience even give to somebody
talk
let's talk through it and
i mean
it's uh
the thera
she deals with a lot of ptsd people from
over in afghanistan she kind of has that
she's death kind of where she is
handling it but i think the hardest part
for both of us is this isn't my family
member this isn't
it wasn't something that i caused or i
witnessed i just found the aftermath so
i think that's the hardest thing that
i'm dealing with is like
why do people do this
and then now i'm finding it 18 years
later
and now you're screwing a whole another
it's just a weird thing to try i don't
know what your therapist tells you but i
you know i have an uh unprofessional
opinion
and i think that
look
i'm going to say like this is something
that's going to pop up in your mind for
the rest of your [ __ ] life there's no
way in your 80s you're going to be like
yeah one time i found a [ __ ] dead
body i hope you know what i mean it's
it's forever going to be there
i think over the course of time it will
get better because you'll be able to
understand it a little more but what i
think you really do need to lean into
and this is coming from a parent
is that you [ __ ] found this girl and
sure
you were nine years old when it went
down there's nothing you could have done
to save her but you you really gave that
family peace and um
you know and you [ __ ] solved the case
like that lady's been laying out in the
[ __ ] woods for 18 [ __ ] years it'd
be nice to have her cremated buried
whatever it is that they'd wish
and give her her proper respects because
you know what an ultimate disrespect to
be [ __ ] murdered and dragged in the
woods and then you're just out there
doing whatever like [ __ ] that guy yeah
you really need to look into
leaning to excuse me that that you
you may not have saved a [ __ ] life
but i feel like you saved the family's
sanity at least they know what's going
on and and what happened and they can
now definitively say hey
because even if you thought the
boyfriend did it and you didn't have a
hundred percent fool proof there's
always a doubt in your mind like what if
it was someone else what if it was
what if she did go out in the woods and
[ __ ] shoot her so well she didn't
bury herself so yeah
you know so actually uh she was never
buried he shot her in the head and left
and what just over time the skull went
under the ground uh well the skull
wasn't totally on the ground
i got to stop i'm sorry he just left her
there like that clothed and everything
and for 18 years no one found that
[ __ ] body
threw a deer's carcass over her and then
they just let those decompose i see he
covered it with a dead deer jesus
[ __ ] christ so that's why like you
said the smell doesn't affect anybody
and no one's gonna go lift that [ __ ] up
and look and
exactly um and then they they think that
the skull could have just been bare bear
like buried because it wasn't totally
buried like i could see the
back part right here
they think that it just over time
sediment moving around
animals trying to save whatever they
could
because they said they lucked out that
most her teeth were still there because
rats will eat the teeth because there's
enough calcium in there to survive them
through the winter really
yep
so they said a lot of the time rats will
take the teeth with them to their dens
and stuff like that and eat on them
throughout the day these people have
seen this so many times they know
they're
humans they were they were sitting there
eating donuts it just it's it's the
normal it's the normal thing for them
drinking a cup of coffee it's my monday
it's my monday so whatever what was it
that they ultimately uh
used to identify or was it dental
records was it dna like was there a
dental and i think some sort of dna from
the bone marrow okay
because but i don't think there was a
whole lot of that but i think they can
piece again pieces together enough of
the dental records because they said
that most her teeth were still there but
they had to find her bottom jaw to be
sure
it was off
yeah so the animal was really ripped
and they said that
this so when you're i don't know if you
know anything you're
about this your skull is not smooth
yeah
i took human anatomy and physiology this
skull was
this call was the skull was smooth
so like tote
rolled
i mean illinois we get snow rain in the
same day
so it was getting just pounded with the
elements it finally just
it rounded itself off so that skull or
that jaw could have just fallen off
one of the 12 times it was you know sure
and there's no saying where that skull
where you found it was not necessarily
where she was shot and killed they think
that it was actually pretty close
because of the majority of the bones
that were there they said that there was
they found a big pile right around that
area so it's not and there's nothing big
enough out there that could drag
a full human around no bear out there or
anything like that no we don't have a
whole lot of bears just the football
team
[Laughter]
[Music]
so they think that that's kind of like
well this within 10 or 15 feet of that
area they cuz it was right under some
brush some low-lying tree you know but
who knows 18 years ago what that could
have looked like
man that's heavy dude that's heavy you
found a human
you found a [ __ ] person a real person
that had
family and [ __ ] friends and loved
ones right before well and it was 18
years ago do they know the month she was
killed like do they know the time frame
she actually was killed i i don't know
about that i didn't like i said in the
article it didn't really have a whole
they just had found who it was
they said they had found a missing
person and they were pursuing action
with it
and then they gave her credit for it
yep i mean
so then just hearing through um my
cousin's my cousin's cousin
is worked for the police department for
the state for that town and he kind of
filled me in on some stuff that was
happening so
so we're here first what has your
therapist told you
it's just like
kind of along the same lines what you
said it's not there's nothing you could
have done it was
you know at the end of the day you're
saving some you're not saving a person
but you're helping a family get through
and saving that family and
i don't want to say there's i have guilt
i i just kind of well
talk about that because i i know of like
survivors guild i've heard of things
like that people on airplanes that like
maybe five people live out and they have
these horrible survivors guilt like why
me
you know i'm i imagine you've asked
yourself at least why me why am i the
guy that [ __ ] found this and solved
this case
yeah it's definitely i i have asked
myself that some nights you know like
why am i the one that
i why am i the one that found it or
why what in the univer in the universe
said you know you need to find this and
it'll be fine
and then
just getting that connection and i i
feel a little guilty but like you said i
can't i couldn't have done anything but
you feel that guilt where it's like
man
or my big thing is the guilt that if
what if i would have never found it
because the next couple days they were
having these big trucks come in that
would have just crushed it and you would
have never seen it again is that right
yeah because they to cut down the trees
what they do in illinois is we have like
uh pretty much a um
a backhoe with just a giant saw in it
that they run and can just clear cut
trees at one time because they're so
thin so yeah
if that would have if a tree would have
fallen on it you would have never seen
it again right or they would have never
thought twice about it yep because
hey this is where we used to drop deer
so any bones don't worry about it type
stuff
so you know why why did i find it four
days three days before they were
supposed to be able to like obviously
there's got to be a reason so
it was just
i i think i live more with the what if i
wasn't paying attention
or what if i didn't go to this tree to
take a leak and then i found it i mean
all these things think about this think
about this let's go back even deeper
your father has a son
who's going to solve this [ __ ] murder
think about that
think about how all the way back it goes
yeah okay i mean and also think about
this because i'm tripping on this 18
years how many people do you think
walked right [ __ ] by and or over that
area in 18 years it had to be more than
just you
well the other guy we uh
we were going to look in to see because
he had originally done the toppo of the
area so he had shot up you know any of
the elevation or any of the trees and
stuff like that
and we were gonna if i would have shot
it with my gps we could have seen where
how close he had put a shot
so that would but i was not thinking
about that when uh
i found that so i didn't do that but i
know some of the guys that worked there
used to play paintball back there
yes i'm saying right so you know like
it's
it's it's kind of at the end of the day
i don't think i had
choice you it chose you
was
a
it did yeah and it found you it looked
right at you joe
[Music]
for christ
it's rude to ignore people and then make
eye contact
so yeah i mean it was
be honest with me about something
when that skull popped up and it made
eye contact with you did you let out a
or a gasper what was the immediate
reaction of of uh you know a visceral
reaction
my first words were no [ __ ] way
[Laughter]
did you know
like jesus christ
i've stumbled back a little bit
and uh luckily i had just peed like just
peed on it because i was like do you
know how close would you pee to it don't
lie all right 15 i had to tell the
police that my dna is over there
[Music]
that's got nothing to do with the body
after
that's not a bullet hole actually
it's been a long week
no i uh i let out a little like what the
no and then
i stumbled back and i go i gotta call my
dad right now and then he's like well
you should probably go to the truck
do you still have the picture of the
skull on your phone
uh i do uh so i have the picture of um
the tape or the police tape around it
and you can see the
the
back of the the skull popping out you
have to really zoom in but i kind of
have it circled it's not a very great
picture because i was
doing this when i was trying to take it
i was like yeah this is fine i'm
throwing up like
a shot over here
what uh my second one how often how
often do you look at it
not often actually when people ask
i gotta go back actually i don't look at
it off enough i have to go back and try
to find it so it's not like it's a
normal thing let me ask you this i know
from my own personal traumas and things
when when you go through something i've
never been through anything like this
but when you go through something
dramatic there are these these vivid
moments
uh pictures if you will that are burned
and frozen in your head what still
images
uh do you see from this like and and
what what flashes do really stick out
um so
like if i'm having a nightmare about it
that i have sometimes
um you have a recurring one it's always
the same it's the same one i mean i
probably once every couple months it's
not like it's every single night or it's
you know weed bro joe you gotta smoke
weed you won't even dream
you won't even dream you you know you'll
do that [ __ ] rem [ __ ] that you don't
remember but you won't even dream i wish
i could but because we do uh federal
work it's still not legal so i can't
he's out of [ __ ] feds
but it always starts with me just
walking in hitting the stick and it
putting up right at me
and then it
and then i it flashes to me climbing
over this uh
the logs that i had set i had actually
set those logs so i could cross the
creek
and it cuts to that and me just looking
down at myself
and just wanting to get back to the
truck and then
my next thing i remember is
i remember the sheriff's face
like i could if you gave me a lineup of
100 guys all dressed the exact same way
i would know exactly which one he was
really i just i can picture it he's got
he's it's a very
square face with a light very light
brown he's got an extended jaw and a
mustache and just how his eyes looked he
had he had like a wart or some sort of
thing right here i can just picture him
like he's sitting right here like i have
a picture of him i can just picture that
right there next to me wow and then uh
but my main one that when i'm talking
about it that i kind of my brain just
keeps going back to
has to be
either the vomit covered truck i don't
know why you see that like the aftermath
of that just just that and me having to
go to the car wash
they're uh
we're just it's [ __ ] so now the next
time i'm in a car wash i'm gonna think
like that car right there might be
getting washed as that guy threw up on
and found the devil
[Laughter]
you never [ __ ] know it's crazy dude
or that snapshot of me just turning down
and it's
it's never when i think about it it's
never me looking at the skull it's like
me from a third person looking at me
looking what i want to ask you are you
hovering over yourself seeing what the
the the scene play out you're not your
own point of view when you look down
you're looking down and seeing you not
your legs i'm looking as if i was from
that
um
the bridge i made right like i could see
like
so like i couldn't make out anything i
can't hear myself but i can see myself
enough through the woods where i'm like
i know exactly what's happening i can
see myself starting to walk and i can
see myself kind of perk up when i see
the rot the rock because i don't want to
slip
and then i can
see it all play out and then it like
fast forwards to me walking the cops
through the through the woods to find it
and then it fast forwards to this and it
fast forwards to this and it's like but
it's all still there watching from third
person but it's just like you just hit
fast forward on the vhs
so that's that's that's
who you know if i have a dream like that
i'll wake up and then i'll go back to
bed and be fine are you waking up
screaming or anything or just disturbed
just waking up like what and then i
realize i'm back home and i just go
right back to bed do you know her name i
can't remember if i asked you because i
i
i don't know how to pronounce it do you
know her first name i don't know how to
pronounce either her name
you don't know how to pronounce any of
it
so uh
um
listen man thank you so much for coming
on and sharing the story this is [ __ ]
awesome man you you really helped the
family and close the cold case that's
crazy good for you man
uh thanks for having me man yeah i
really do appreciate you coming on and
look for those of you out there uh who
have a story that needs to be heard look
you don't need to be a patreon member
and it doesn't need to be you if you've
got someone you know that's like my
grandfather's a great [ __ ] look
i want to hear from him let's hear these
stories this is unlike anything you've
heard
uh this is fantastic joe again thank you
so much so if you have that story please
submit it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com
be patient we'll get back to you uh
we're gonna look through all of them um
and again
five bucks a month all right if you're
new here and you're considering staying
longer go for the year you'll get over a
month of free episodes
um you get the entire back catalog video
and audio options as well as the
honeydew a day early ad-free all right
thank you all so much for your support i
sincerely appreciate it come out and see
me on the night pants nation tour y'all
we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
you